some say there has never been a chess
player as great as bobby fischer a
leading russian opponent described him
as an achilles without an achilles heel
fischer was not only known for being a
chest genius but also for spiraling into
insanity this video will take you
through his highs and his lows
bobby fischer was born in chicago on
march 9 1943 and raised in brooklyn by
single mother from switzerland born to
jewish parents they were poor regina
fischer didn't even have the money to
patch up bobby's torn shoes when he was
a kid regina was divorced from hans
gerhart fisher a german biophysicist but
bobby's actual father was most likely
the result of an affair with her friend
paul nemene a hungarian jewish physicist
when bobby was six his sister joanne
bought him a chess set and taught him to
play he felt chess was more exciting
than monopoly because no luck was
involved and he found it far more
challenging
his sister soon grew tired of the game
and his mother was busy working as a
teacher and a nurse so bobby spent
several hours every day playing against
himself he loved the thousands of
possible moves and the complex strategy
involved after a year of this his mother
took him to the brooklyn chess club
where he got lessons a couple of times a
week with one of the club's best players
carmen nigro nigro charged him a dollar
an hour but bobby believes he wasn't in
it for the money but simply to make sure
he took the lessons seriously and
apparently he did he was utterly
obsessed with chess one might even say
it was his best friend
actually fisher didn't have any real
friends growing up he thought having
friends was only important for kids who
had secrets and wanted someone to share
them with he had no secrets so
apparently he didn't feel the need to
have friends fisher would spend sundays
playing chess with [ __ ] in manhattan's
washington square park he began spending
less time with nigro when he started
being tutored by jack collins a master
player who once ranked as high as number
17 in the us cullen spent his life in a
wheelchair he didn't quite fit in just
like fisher he was careful not to say he
was fisher's coach that would be like
saying someone had to coach beethoven
shakespeare or leonardo da vinci he
thought fisher was a genius on the level
of those geniuses
collins did have an extensive library
collection of chess books which fisher
devoured spending five to ten hours a
day reading and studying he would need
the preparation when he faced older and
more experienced opponents
when fisher was 13 years old he faced 26
year old donald byrne one of the top 10
players in america fisher played in
black burn in white
the game of the century as it's
remembered took place in new york city
on october 17 1956.
fisher's moves looked like lethal art he
even dared to sacrifice his queen
fisher got a thrill out of breaking his
opponent's ego his opponent was
outclassed and outmatched this game put
fisher on the map the world knew it had
a genius on its hands
the following year when he was still
only 14 years old he won the u.s
championship a year later he became the
youngest ever
and in 1972 he captured the world
championship from the soviet union's
boris baskey
this was stunning the soviets lived and
breathed chess they were more obsessed
than canadians are about hockey or the
chinese about table tennis then comes
along a lone wolf from america who was
up against the entire soviet chess
institution it was a david versus
goliath match-up bobby fischer
single-handedly beat the soviets at
their own game this took place during
the cold war and the symbolism wasn't
lost on anyone the world's two
superpowers battled it out on a
chessboard except fischer nearly skipped
the match of the century he refused to
fly to reykjavik iceland for the
tournament unless he got more money
including a guarantee of a slice of the
lucrative tv revenue u.s secretary of
state henry kissinger had to insist he
quote get his butt over to iceland
he finally flew there after a british
investment banker offered to double the
money to 250 000 fischer was still in a
foul mood when he arrived he played
poorly during the first match and lost
he didn't even show up for the second
match complaining that the tv cameras
distracted him so he lost automatically
the tournament organizers conceded to
his demands for the third match to be
played without tv cameras in the room
from that point on his playing got
stronger fisher the 29 year old who
dropped out of high school would beat
spassky to become world champion
single-handedly dismantling the soviet
union's 24-year hold on the game
he became a hero to millions of
americans and inspired new interest in
the game of chess some chess clubs saw
membership double during the fisher
frenzy he was a star and made the rounds
of american tv on the carson tonight
show he showed off his brilliance by
solving a sliding puzzle in 17 seconds
this was not very well mixed up i want
to
say that it wasn't well mixed up
oh 17. no well they didn't mix it up too
well it takes about 30 seconds
he reportedly had an iq of 181 which is
said to be even higher than albert
einstein's although he scaled the
heights of fame fisher wasn't all that
likable he had a habit of saying
controversial things though people
tended to ignore it because he was the
cold war chess hero after all this is
what he once said about female chess
players in an interview with the
canadian broadcasting corporation the
women are really very good players i
mean i guess i could give every one of
them a night and still win easily
why is this do we want to make bad chess
players oh they're terrible chess
players
i mean some are better than others you
know but uh
why they may not play in men's
tournaments
i don't know why i guess they just are
so smart
would you call yourself a misogynist
excuse me what's the definition of that
a woman hater no
no
what do you think of women
when it comes to chess
not too much he managed to offend
everyone during an interview with the
philippine radio station hours after 9
11. he said the attacks were quote
wonderful news i applaud the act the u.s
and israel have been slaughtering the
palestinians just slaughtering them for
years i want to see the u.s wiped out
he never hit his hatred of jews
repeatedly making anti-semitic remarks
despite being jewish ethnically his
anti-american anti-semitic comments
coincided with his growing paranoia he
decided the us government was out to get
him he also believed the israeli
national intelligence agency the mossad
was after him he refused to defend his
world championship title in 1975. he
complained that opponents were trying to
poison his food his hotel rooms were
bugged he feared the russians wanted to
bomb his plane
for years fisher carried a blue
cardboard box with him wherever he went
and refused to say what was inside once
when he went to use the restaurant
restroom he left it on the table and a
friend he was with peeked inside he saw
a bible
religion appealed to his desire for
logic and order
except he later cut ties with a
worldwide church of god funded by
televangelist after complaining that
herbert armstrong's teachings made
members lose their minds and become
zombies one of the sure signs of his
mental decline was that he insisted on
removing his dental fillings he
explained that he didn't want anything
artificial in him and had heard of a guy
wounded in world war ii who had a metal
blade in his head that picked up
vibrations and even radio transmissions
his mental instability manifested in his
physical appearance gone was the
athletic young man who swam and played
tennis to keep in shape for chess which
requires enormous mental and physical
endurance he was now unrecognizable
california police officers mistakenly
arrested him because he resembled a man
wanted for robbery he spent 48 hours in
jail and wrote a book about the alleged
torture he endured during his descent
into madness bobby fischer didn't play a
single competitive game of chess in
public for 20 years but eventually he
had to because he had run out of money
in 1992 he agreed to a 5 million dollar
rematch against his russian arch-rival
spassky in yugoslavia however the us
government wasn't too pleased about that
it defied u.n sanctions against the
war-torn country americans were
forbidden from doing any business in
yugoslavia fisher was warned he'd face
10 years in prison if he went ahead with
his plans but he didn't care he won the
tournament
some believe he was coaxed into playing
by his teenage hungarian girlfriend zida
riccini who was also a chess player she
had apparently turned a pen pal
relationship into a romance despite
their 30-year age gap although fisher
claimed he didn't have time for women he
is said to have married a japanese chess
player miyoko watai and lived with her
in japan for a few years he reportedly
hoped that as the spouse of a japanese
citizen he could stay there as he had
been on the run from american
authorities for defying sanctions but
his attempt to stay in japan was
unsuccessful authorities arrested him
for using a passport that had been
revoked by the us government he begged
iceland to take him in the country that
made him famous in 1972 iceland welcomed
him by making him a citizen he would
spend the rest of his days there living
in obscurity
so what caused bobby fischer to descend
into madness
some speculate that training in
blindfold chess can cause mental strain
as you can't see or touch the pieces so
you're forced to maintain a mental image
in your head however there were signs
something was not right with bobby
fischer much earlier on
legendary chess grandmaster mikhail tal
picked up on it back in the 50s mocking
fisher for being cuckoo another chess
grandmaster paul benko once remarked i'm
not a psychiatrist but it was obvious he
was not normal i told him you are
paranoid and he said that paranoids can
be right
world-renowned chess grandmaster and
psychoanalyst dr ruben fine described in
his book on fisher that fisher's mother
had consulted him because she was
concerned her teenage son was too
obsessed with chess and felt he needed
friends and other hobbies fine described
how when he quote started a conversation
with fisher at one point about what he
was doing in school as soon as school
was mentioned he became curious screamed
you have tricked me and promptly walked
out
for years afterward whenever i met him
in clubs or tournaments he gave me angry
looks as though i had done him some
immeasurable harm by trying to get a
little closer to him in other words
fischer reacted in a paranoid way
perhaps school was a sensitive spot he
dropped out at the age of 16 to focus on
chess he was always insecure about his
lack of education and decided to trade
his casual wear for suits when playing
chess in order to look more
sophisticated
social skills were not his forte when
cbs's 60 minutes spent his 29th birthday
with him and surprised him with a cake
he actually refused it
happy birthday to you you were worrying
about this
why were you worrying about it
you know i just don't go first of all i
don't eat this kind of cake
second of all i'll go for these things
all right
should we take it away please
it appears paranoia ran in his family
the fbi described fischer's mother
regina as mentally unstable in their
secret files on her they had spied on
her since the dawn of the cold war in
the 1940s the fbi suspected that the
left-leaning political activist was a
communist spy both she and her then
husband had lived in russia the agency
was also worried that the russians had
tried to recruit bobby bobby's
relationship with his mother was
strained he resented her for abandoning
him when he was a teen so she could
focus on her medical career although
they hardly saw each other over the
years he is said to have become
distraught after she passed away in 1997
quickly followed by his sister the
following year some believe their deaths
caused him to lose whatever last grasp
he had on reality
bobby's probable father was also
believed to be paranoid paul nemene was
highly intelligent he even collaborated
with einstein's son hans albert einstein
who was also a scientist
nemeni emigrated from hungary to the us
in 1939 but had trouble adjusting he
reportedly walked around with soap in
his pockets paranoid about getting his
hands dirty
some speculate bobby fischer could have
had schizophrenia or asperger's though
there was no evidence that he was
diagnosed with any mental health
disorders it also does not appear that
fisher had any long-term treatment for
mental health issues
one could only wonder if his life would
have turned out differently if he did
during the last years of his life he
stayed in close touch with a
psychiatrist who headed iceland's
hospital for the criminally insane dr
magnus glasin stayed in hospital with
fisher as he lay dying of kidney failure
fischer passed away on january 17 2008
and according to scalasen his final
words were
nothing is as healing as the human touch
coming from a man who shied away from
social contact
this was a remarkable thing to hear
it was fitting that having fallen in
love with 64 black and white squares on
a chessboard bobby fischer died when he
was 64 years old
he asked to be buried as a catholic
[Music]
bobby fischer once wrote an article for
the boy scouts magazine
quote with talent study and a positive
attitude there is no limit to how far
you can go
yet he failed to live up to his own
words
if fischer had stayed in the game longer
perhaps we would have seen a match-up
with gary kasparov arguably the two
greatest chess players of all time
though they were 20 years apart
but it would never come to pass
the person who finally defeated bobby
fischer was sadly
himself
documentaries like these command a lot
of my energy i try to stay as energized
and relaxed as possible which is why i
trust magnesium breakthrough by by
optimizers i have trouble sleeping so
i've been taking magnesium breakthroughs
since the start of this year and ever
since my sleep has gotten a lot better i
hardly wake up during the middle of the
night and i've noticed also during my
day i just feel a lot better and more
energized most magnesium supplements are
synthetic or use preservatives when you
get all seven critical forms of
magnesium like you do with magnesium
breakthrough your body gets a serious
upgrade so you can feel better
throughout your day to find out more
head to magnesiumbreakthrough.com
newsthink to get a 10 discount my custom
link is in my description and pin
comment and don't forget to use my promo
code newsthink10 at checkout thanks for
watching for newsthink i'm cindy palm